It started as an idea.
What if we made a Deadpool movie?
There was only a few of us back then,
and looking back
we had no idea how big it would become.
So innocent.
And yet the momentum that had started,
it was not really what we had in mind,
though.
That didn't help things.
It was more of a hell no.
To be honest.
I mean, we eventually stopped asking.
We have no idea how that happened.
But I promise you, I'm looking into it.
But once the movie got greenlit,
I went on a massive coke bender.
So 2016, this little hazy for me.
They tell me the movie did well, though
ten years into it,
phase
one has exceeded our wildest expectations.
Zero.
If you told me back then
that one movie would spawn an expansive
two movie universe,
I have said that you were crazy.
But here we are with actual actors.
A moderate special effects budget
and several low level X-Men.
None of the big ones, though.
We've got to save something for phase two.
Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
There's a brand new Deadpool 3 First,
look at a couple of scenes.
They're filming with Ryan Reynolds,
Deadpool and what's going on with Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine in the yellow costume
that he'll be wearing from the comics,
as well as a couple other brand new cameos
that we just learned about.
So we'll break it all down. Oh, Wow.
Oh, my God.
wow, wow, wow, wow.
so now what we see is
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
they'll be thumbing for a while.
So we'll continue getting scenes.
But this is getting crazier and crazier
the more we learn about it.
the first new Deadpool
three scenes that we got to look at are
Deadpool Ryan Reynolds versus
the TVA in the woods.
Look kind of like the Canadian wilderness,
similar
to the end of the Logan movie
in a couple of the other Wolverine movies
the beat a couple of times in the X-Men
universe that we visited the Canadian
wilderness, where Logan's been living
there during various points in his life.
you know, notice
Deadpool suit is a little bit different
from his Deadpool two suit,
which is just meant to be his Deadpool
one suit that he'd patched up over time.
So that might be the explanation here
with this version of the suit
is it in the time since Deadpool one,
it just continued to get busted?
He's slowly patched up more and more,
and that's why
it looks a little bit different.
but in the scene, he's
running from a bunch of TVA
agents that are coming out of that car
trying to chase him down.
love the way that it looks like
the most normal, most average car
that you've ever seen your entire life.
Like nothing special,
just some random car that the TVA agents
are able to steal
to try and chase them down.
we also learned Wolverine's yellow suit
that he's going to be
wearing from the comics or one of
the Wolverines will be wearing the main
version will be based on his yellow suit
from the astonishing X-Men run.
The yellow suit from the Wolverine movie
is something slightly
different from the comics,
but based on the comic book Yellow Suits,
Most of it
will be practical, like the Deadpool suit.
But they use a little bit
of special effects
to try and tune it up
the way they do with the Deadpool suit.
They use special effects
to make his eyes emote.
they did the same thing for Anthony
Mackie's Captain America
when he got his brand new Captain America
suit in Falcon and Winter Soldier.
The suit was practical,
but they use special effects,
which just polish it a little bit.
You have to imagine, though,
you special effects to tune up his helmet
just a little bit
just because the pieces are just so crazy.
they ever said what
every single version of Deadpool
and Wolverine
are going to look like in the movie,
But they'll all be radically different
looking like
they won't be the exact same versions.
and I believe they'll also have a joke,
kind of like the Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantumania joke,
where one of the versions of Ant-Man
still worked at Baskin-Robbins.
It was just a normal version of Scott Lang
walked in with his uniform.
It'll be like a normal version of Ryan
Reynolds wearing a Wrexham soccer shirt.
There are a couple other huge cameos
that they just confirmed in one of them.
Big surprise I wasn't expecting.
This was Jennifer Garner
coming back as her Elektra
from the Ben Affleck Daredevil movies.
But it makes sense if Ben Affleck's
daredevil is coming back in a big way,
why wouldn't she also come back too?
If she's from that universe
now, it's not clear if her
cameo scene will be during the Ben Affleck
daredevil cameo scene.
I did a whole video on his daredevil
coming back.
That's going to be nuts.
we've got to the point in Ben Affleck's
career where he's kind of past superhero
movies, but he's happy to come back
and do one off cameo scenes.
his. Elektra might show up
in a completely different scene
because Deadpool is jumping
through a bunch of different universes
with cable's time travel device, but
because they're from the same universe,
It makes sense
that Daredevil and Ben Affleck's
Elektra would show up in the same scene.
The crazy thing in real life is that
they also got married around that period
when those movies were coming out and
have since been divorced for a while now.
I'm sure they'd be open
to joking about their history
in real life together,
but I'm not sure that their character
will take it that far.
Like, I don't know how big their cameo
scene will be
a lot of people
will also remember the Jennifer Garner
Elektra movie that they did
after the Ben Affleck Daredevil movie.
Her name is Electra.
Like the tragedy.
And parents
must have had a sense of humor.
Not really.
It is a treat if you haven't seen it.
It's a bit of a slog to make it through.
It was not a great movie. But.
I think
when the movie gets ready to come out,
there'll be like, this rite of passage
amongst the fandom.
Well, you have to go back
and you have to rewatch
all the movies that they're going
to reference during this, which include
all the old Fox X-Men movies,
even the bad ones.
Usually when we talk about Marvel movies,
everybody wants to know what the best
Marvel movies are.
But when a lot of these movies come back
to be referenced, we'll have to make lists
about what the worst Marvel movies are
because there are so many of them now.
Like of all the bad Marvel movies,
which ones are the actual worst?
when you talk about bad Marvel movies
bad Marvel series there's terrible.
Like things
that are so bad that they're fun to watch
and things that are just plain bad
that are not fun to watch.
we learned a little bit more about Emma,
Karen's villain character.
Supposedly,
she's not playing the main villain
Like a lot of the Hollywood trades
reported before.
supposedly she's playing one of the TVA
judges, kind of like Ren Slayer
was at the beginning of season
one before she had
the big turn at the end of the season.
So Emma, Karen's judge character, still
an antagonist to Deadpool and Wolverine,
but she's not the main villain supposedly
the main villain will be a familiar face
because we're talking about a lot of X-Men
coming back from the X-Men movies,
Fantastic Four characters coming back,
it makes a little more sense
that they would have the main villain
be somebody that everyone's familiar
with from those movies.
there's also a report
that one of the universes
that Deadpool jumps through
is the 838 universe from the Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness movie.
So they'll pay off
some of the things that happened
after the events of that movie.
supposedly the story, that universe
just continues from the end of the movie
in the surviving members of the Illuminati
still want revenge against
616 main MCU Scarlet Witch For killing.
Most of their team in the surviving
members are supposed to at least
be mordo in the superior
Iron Man that they cut from the story.
but here's the thing
with the familiar face
that might wind up
being the main villain of the movie.
If the movie goes to a universe
that's meant to be based on the house of M
from the comics a lot of the people
reporting all these cameos, scenes
that they've
since confirmed are also saying
the quote unquote mummy is coming back.
And I think the mummy
they're referencing is Elizabeth Olsen.
Just because of all the Real-Life Memes.
Hi, I'm Elizabeth Olsen.
Some of you may know me as mom.
Oh, gosh.
I just
want to figure out the whole mutant thing.
Like, that's really and I don't like,
none of us can do anything
about it, you know, like,
we can't do anything about it.
We're not born, we're not X-Men.
But, gosh, like, I just.
I just would love to explore that so much.
I think X-Men was definitely
my first experience
with superhero type films.
so what might be happening
is they're bringing back
a version of Scarlet Witch
and she'll have created the house of them.
Reality in this alternate universe.
end, either
she winds up being the main villain,
which might be redundant
because she was the villain
in Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness
or if we're talking about a familiar face
being the main villain
and they're bringing back
all these old X-Men Fantastic Four actors.
Maybe that familiar face is a version
of Magneto because Ian McKellen is coming
back as his character, Patrick Stewart
also coming back as well.
so in the House of Reality, Magneto
could just be reigning supreme
and protecting his version of Scarlet
Witch, which he thinks of as his daughter.
They could pay off some Easter eggs about
Scarlet Witch being Magneto's daughter
energies keeping Deadpool and Wolverine
from trying to take down the Scarlet Witch
so they can get rid of the house of
M reality
there's also been a lot of talk
about Elizabeth Olsen coming back
as multiple different versions of her
Scarlet witch from different universes
they're supposed to be a version of her
during the Agatha Harkness
show, Coven of Chaos.
but I think the one that they might be
referencing in the Deadpool three movie
is a completely different universe
version of the character.
the clip of her talking about
wanting to do more X-Men and mutant based
stories
she's been talking about for a while.
But the actual clip itself
is literally from this past weekend.
regardless
of what's going on in Deadpool three,
I believe that Kevin Feige and Marvel
do have plans to explore Scarlet Witch
Crossing over with X-Men characters
during like a Mutant saga
after Avengers six Secret words like
they have more plans for her later on.
whispering the words No more attacks
causing over 90% of mutants
to lose their powers.
There is a ton of death.
Scarlet Witch
fled to wonder Gore Mountain post
all your reactions in the comments below.
I'll do more Deadpool three videos.
When we get more footage from the set
or we learn more about what's going on
with the cameos.
The other X-Men, the Fantastic
Four characters that are coming back,
or other Fox Marvel people in general,
like Ben Affleck's Daredevil click
Here for all my Deadpool
three videos to learn about all the other
big cameos and click here
for all my secret invasion videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!